rather than gals talking to the guys
which is what they're doing I know they
don't think that they're doing that or
they they may not appreciate the gravity
of what they're doing but
you're mostly talking to men I mean all
you have to do is look at the comments
of these videos it's not it's not women
that are paying attention to or to the
degree that you purport to the public
that you think that you're helping you
need you want to help the cows you need
to talk to them about preserving the
value right men's value is created
that's that's one of the core tenets
that I talk about very often it's
discussed in my book any of the good
guys in the man of swamp will talk about
it as well well they'll talk about you
need to level yourself up okay you need
to become a better version yourself
become a competent man you know learn
skills lose the weight develop some
style like we can help men through those
processes
um there's there's phrases that are
usually you know distilled down to like
looks money in game or money muscle's
game or whatever like that it's actually
a longer list than that I did a video
about a year ago and I was talking about
it's more than just that like one of the
other items is of course captivation
which is completely missed a lot of the
times by a lot of the guys in the man of
swamp because
you can be money muscles game frame or
you know whatever the lingo happens to
be but if you're boring as [ __ ] doesn't
matter how much money you have doesn't
matter how jacked you are doesn't matter
how tight your game is whether how you
deal with the negs how you deal with the
you know the [ __ ] tests and all this
sort of stuff it doesn't matter how
tight any of that is if you're boring as
[ __ ] you don't have anything to
invite her in to do she won't be around
for very long so there's some holes in
the Mano swap as I've talked about
before anyway
so
women today uh you know by default
they're the protected sex in society and
we're expected to as guys innately know
to forgive them for any bad choices that
they've made in their past like racked
up a bunch of notches have been with a
whole bunch of guys doesn't matter if
it's five doesn't matter if it's 50 or
500 anything beyond one is unacceptable
according to the statistical data that
is the number one predictor of a great
long-term relationship or marriage
bottom line so there's no need to fix
the problem because you can make more
money and get attention from thirsty
confused beta males right that's the
problem that the gals are perpetrating
on
so guys
you want to learn how to catch a fish
you talk to a seasoned fisherman that
struggles starved and experienced
everything that's who you talk to you
don't ask the fish
I think this was Patrice O'Neal's line
in one of his stand-up comedies those
are those like if you want to go back to
some of the OG's Patrice O'Neill is one
of the OG's when it comes to stuff like
that he used to run this radio show
um I didn't listen to a lot of it but a
lot of the points that he made were all
completely valid and he and he'd go on
these long rants for a long period of
time you'll find a lot of them on
YouTube so if you go to YouTube and you
search you know Patrice O'Neill radio
show you'll find stuff or just you know
Patrice O'Neal on on women you'll find
stuff like that
right now the manosphere does have some
good information I am absolutely
grateful for what I found and got what I
needed to unplug from my own set of
comforting lies but if I'm being honest
today it's run by men that aren't good
men or good at being men I'm going to
talk more about that in a minute
these guys they fight like little girls
there's a lot of drama between them they
sue over very trivial agreements can be
quite nihilistic they lie cheat steal
try to hold women accountable which is
one of my favorite
makes for good good shows though you
know it's pretty funny
um that was like the whole Kevin Samuels
sort of model right uh try way too hard
to look smarter more successful than
they actually are they convinced low
value guys that they can do stupid [ __ ]
like run harems which will never happen
for them so there's a lot of there's a
lot of issues with even the guy creators
too so in this in this video I'm going
to talk about what to look for what to
stay away from and a few of the other
bits but I kind of want to open with
this just to sort of set the tone
anyway uh back to the gal thing
statistically we've seen what a bad job
single moms have done with raising men
there's a lot of data out on this you
can go look it up uh the vast majority
of the incarcerated teenage pregnancies
shitty High School grades uh gang
activity uh run away from home suicide
attempts the vast majority of all d-gen
sort of teenage activity comes from
single mother households unfortunately
um they haven't done a great job at
raising men they they basically create
beta factories that rarely produce the
high value men that women want what
single mother households generally
produce are kind humble they basically
create the kind of guy that they want to
look after them as they get older they
don't create the kind of guy that they
wanted to be with when they were younger
when they were seeking you know the
strong virtuous alpha male sort of thing
they create these weak pussified
compliant agreeable soft beta males that
they often just tell just be yourself
and someday some gal will come along for
you at some point
there's a lot of there's a lot of things
going on behind the scenes obviously now
that you're starting to see this right
uh now women they have the fastest
growing Niche leaning damage thirsty and
Confused men that they really can't
relate to for what's essentially boiled
down to attention and money it's
essentially only fans for the red pill
that's what it is
calling it like it is right I could go
on I'll save it for another day so my
advice overall is take what you need do
the work get out
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out